what's going on reject nation greg here
i'm gonna watch today according to my
email from my buddy this is a comparison
video from ign
from ps4 2018 to the ps5 remaster
2020 of marvel's spider-man i was
talking with him on the phone because
i'm a big fan of the
spider-man game and he said to me this
is literally how the conversation went
he said did you see the remaster trailer
for marvel's spider-man i'm like no i
didn't really have an interest in it at
the time
when it dropped he's like wait so you
don't know anything about it
no i don't know anything about it why
what's wrong look i'm just gonna send
you a link
don't look up anything you just gotta
react to it you gotta react to it the
way he was talking about it
made it sound like that there's
something in here that
might not bode so well i literally have
a link here in my email
i'm gonna watch it let's see
what's in store
there's a little bonus reaction at the
end of this video from john who hasn't
played this game but
after seeing my reaction you're gonna
want to see why i wanted to get the
reaction of someone
who hasn't played the game all right so
right now what i see on screen
is a bottle one looks brighter than the
other
i don't know which one's a remastered
one
hello parker
just in time to celebrate
celebrate
wait where are the arms
oh wow
did they make him look like tom holland
transmission
faster than signals travel inside the
brain never mind to an external
prosthesis
his face
beautifully he looks so young
what wait what
why'd they do that let me watch this
again
why does he look like tom holland
wait where are the arms
so sometimes in the remaster the shading
looks brighter and sometimes it looks a
little darker second the remaster looks
brighter there
looks darker than the original there
again the lighting is shading's shifting
wait a minute why did they do that what
wait it doesn't even look i need to
watch like a clip of this without i need
to watch a clip of this without the
without the side by side hold on a
second
hello parker
just in time to celebrate
celebrate
wait where are the arms
i don't like that
he was he was like perfect before he was
under one perfect faster than signals
travel
inside the brain never mind doing
external prosthesis
excuse me
that does not look good to me oh
i gotta go to the commons what are
people saying
holy [ __ ] this is
this is like the sonic the hedgehog
movie but in reverse
currently i'm looking at this is the
remastered of the marvel spider-man
um just uh not a side-by-side currently
on game spot 13k dislikes 10k
likes so let me go to igns which has way
more views
all right it's nowhere near as bad but i
i don't know about that man uh
i think they done botched that
everything around this whole scene
generally looks about the same but
looking at it here
in terms of like a side-by-side
comparison or just up front he looks a
lot
younger they clearly wanted him to look
like tom holland i don't get the point
of doing that this feels like a reverse
sonic the hedgehog situation where they
had a
perfect game and a perfect peter parker
and then
for some reason they decided to
completely redesign him
you know i'm sure the game will still be
great i'm sure the gameplay will still
be fine
but a big part of the attachment to the
storyline in this game was
peter parker himself where there's cut
scenes with peter parker i honestly
think the voice
of whoever i'm sorry i don't know the
actor who voices him but the voice actor
of him i don't know if just because i'm
more used to the original one
but i think his voice matches much
better with the original one too
be so funny if they changed it back
[Laughter]
it's not funny in the sense of these
poor animators and all the hard work
they're doing
man i i don't get the i really don't see
what the intention of this
is if we change his whole face it'll
feel like a different game if we make
him look like tom holland people who
didn't care to play the game will now
play the game
you might as well have changed doc ock
to look like alfred molina
this is not ha this is not making me
happy not gonna lie it's not making me
happy at all
to me it's kind of funny that they would
do this oh crap i'm still gonna play it
i know i know me i'm still gonna i'm
gonna get the ps5 remastered version
anyway
i know as much of it an initial like i'm
i'm honestly surprised i'm baffled i'm
really baffled by this this is this kind
of caught me off guard peter parker's
supposed to look like he's in his
mid-20s in this game
he's like 25-26 looks like a 17-year-old
here it doesn't
just doesn't fit do you guys not care do
you guys sway on the side where you want
them to change it back
will this make you not get the ps5
remastered version leave your thoughts
down below
whoa that was surprising anyway
thanks for being here one sec guys i
gotta i want to see something
hey john i have a scene so we're going
to
okay i just watched this video and i
know you haven't played the spider-man
game what i wanted to do
was for someone who hasn't played the
game
i want to see if this makes you want to
play the game more or something
or what your opinion is of it i know you
haven't played it so i want to see
like if it makes you go you know what
with this design maybe i'll be more
inclined to play or something okay
okay no pressure no pressure no man just
be yourself
be honest do you want to watch the
comparison one or do you want to watch
the one without the comparison
uh i guess i would like to see the one
without the comparison so we're going
completely
okay okay
i don't know what to expect right now
hello parker
just in time to celebrate
celebrate
wait where are the arms
oh wow that's so cool
uh how did you intro cranial neural
network
neurotransmission speeds under one
nanosecond
faster than signals traveling inside the
brain never mind to an external
prosthesis we did it peter
no one can take this away from us
amazing and your work on the neural web
wiki
but we haven't even tested it yet
there's so much we don't know it works
beautifully
come on take a look
anyway that's peter parker okay
so he's a scrawny kid from from new york
i guess well he's supposed to be 26.
oh i think i think he's 26. okay how old
does he look to you there
he he looks like he's in high school
yeah
he looks like a lanky kid
he looks like he just got out of a
locker is there an actor he looks like
uh i mean he
you know i feel like they want him to
look a little reminiscent of tom holland
but he just reminds me of the kid from
wrinkle and time
all right so here's like a glimpse at
the remastered right
so left is the original oh
see how much of a difference they made
that is yeah
celebrate
he looks older in the original yeah
he looks way older
there are times the original just looks
better in general
yeah it's weird it's like the the
shading and the the
it's like the darker richer yeah
wow that is a shock
that is a different character model
it works beautifully come on take a look
peter 20 20 peter looks like an adult
the same way like grant gustin
just looks like a stretched out kid well
for someone who hasn't played the game
yeah do you have a preference
i think i prefer the older one
just because i get given the context at
least it looks a little richer in the
colors weirdly enough i mean some of the
brights
in the remaster look a little more maybe
i don't know photo real but yeah the
image looks a bit richer and peter looks
a lot more like a 26 year old
damn all right well is this a
controversy
i think but hey what are you gonna do to
not remaster anymore
yes avoid this again
while i have you here let's do a page
for the day shadow
andrew of the haze andrew hayes i don't
know why this video made me think of you
maybe it's because of your cherubic good
looks and the fact that you look
way younger than you actually are and i
think that as you continue to age you're
just going to continue to look
even younger than before so yeah it's
like regenerating
get that wolverine reference for your
hat but yeah you're gonna you know have
this timeless quality and every year
it's gonna be like you're remastered and
every year i'm gonna be like
what gives i don't believe you anymore
andrew one thing i always believe
is the pledge that is concrete my friend
that you can take to the bunk
seriously love you buddy hope you're
doing well
and hey if you get your mitts on this
let me know which version you prefer
you